the secret to my success is the two
mentors I have my mentors may be rich
Juanes or get a mentor whatsup believe
nation is heaven I believe in you and
this channel is designed to be a part of
your daily success routine so today
let's learn from one of the best day
lock and how and why to find mentors
mentor me Dan
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one learn from the right person over the
years I have read thousands of books
I've attended thousands of trainings and
workshops but I could tell you without a
doubt without any hesitation the secret
to my success is the two mentors I have
my mentors may be rich the books I read
they help seminars I went to they helped
but my two mentors they are truly my
secret weapon
to success how does my mentor make me
rich first of all your mentor has
absolutely no obligation to make you
rich you have to understand that first
come from that place your mentor is
where you want to be in your dreams and
I think most people sometimes they see
someone online unfortunately they see
someone on social media or they follow
somebody and say oh that's my mentor I
don't believe in that I think you need
to choose your mentor very very
carefully I think who you learn from
it's much much more important than what
you learned
just like in martial art who is your
seafood who is your son say who's your
instructor it's much more important than
a style that you learn a true mentor is
life-changing so if anything you should
think about look at the person actually
look at the person look at the mentor
look at the people you follow get beyond
all the fancy and the glam another glitz
and audition do I resonate with this
person right do I do I connect with this
person do I connect with a mentor do I
do I feel like I understand do I feel
like a values are our line I think
that's very critical who you learn from
it's your gonna learn from this person
this is this is your gonna be more like
this person last thing you want is you
learn more from this guy become more an
[ __ ] then then what's the point am i
learning Beyond and want you to say you
want to learn business you want to be
successful hopefully you're not just
learning how to be I'll learn how to
make money from this person from this
mentor hopefully you're learning other
things beyond the
just that one thing you wanna learn
because I think a true mentor is someone
who is not just teaching you whatever
it's leading by example as a role model
they're teaching you or other aspects of
life it's not just one thing very linear
approach right so I think you need to be
more less selective who you learn from
and I think you need to consider is this
that when I learned from my mentor never
go to mentor with a sense of entitlement
I see this on YouTube a lot right just
from their comment and order hey Dan I
watched a video man help me out
I have a question help me out what if
should I help you out not that I don't
want to help you out but you don't even
get the basics of business dude any
business interaction the first thing you
should ask is how can I add value how
could I add value to my mentor both are
mentors that I have I added value to
their lives
ask them how could I help you the first
mentor I had if you watch any one of my
work you know Alan I worked for him for
next to nothing for one year
the second mentor I pay him tens of
thousands of dollars to learn from I
invest in myself I'm not in vain not
paying my mentor I'm not investing my
mentor I'm investing in myself through
my mentor you have to understand that
rule number two invest in a relationship
so when looking for a mentor yes let's
say we take you out of the picture yeah
all right how do you know if they are in
in this just to to be a guru and sell
you [ __ ] or if they're actually are able
to help you you don't you don't it's
like how do you know it's a any single
people in the room okay couple of people
now how do you know when going a day
that that's gonna be the one you just
don't know but you will find out pretty
quickly you will find out pretty quickly
you look at this stuff you connect with
them are they being helpful are they
actually helping you right and you can
see well you know yeah it is helpful
then you know you keep you continue
relationship the good thing about this
relationship versus like a marriage it
doesn't work you can you can stop
anytime you can stop calling them you
can stop asking them questions so I
think it's not being afraid just to ask
and say like just today is interests
today I just finished an interview with
a gentleman called cocktail for my
podcast
just before I came here and he is very
successful zero entrepreneur company
doing about 50 60 million dollars a year
raised about a hundred million dollars
and at the end of the interview I said
hey no Dell can I can I can I ask you
some stuff can I hire you can I can you
be my mentor he said well you know then
I'm quite busy but even you need help
yes your mentor I just asked and I said
I'm more than happy to pay you
I pay my mentors don't feel like it's
not so much that your mentor doesn't
need your money
you understand that but paying them it's
it's some skin in the game and they know
you're serious it's just like I have
probably now a 12 a does entrepreneurs
they pay me a thousand bucks a month for
an hour of my time every month thousand
bucks an hour you know it's not only the
money but if they pay that 1,000 bucks I
know that they're serious and they're
gonna implement what I teach them that's
that's fine that's totally fine so I do
that little bit you know in my spare
time but that's what I mean don't be
afraid it you know invest in your mentor
you know I buy my mentor gifts I just
like my mentor my Dan Pena seventh
birthday SMI nice gift
how can you expect your mentor to invest
in a relationship when you don't even
spend a time and effort in the
relationship it makes no sense you want
them to help you you want them to help
you grow you want them to help you
succeed but what have you done for them
what have you shown nothing they don't
need anything from you
and I'm always very humble very grateful
more my mentors I always thank them I
appreciate what they've done because it
is it is because of what they've helped
me to do so that's what I would say
don't be afraid you know you will know
but all you can do is ask and then do it
and rule number three the last one
before a very special bonus clip is
observed add value first and then don't
suck up their time observe like don't
like don't be so stupid
ask them stupid watch if you're smart my
mentors both of them first Alan he never
directly taught me anything
he never sat down you do a B C and D
unlike this we're kind of the mentorship
I'm giving you over over videos it's a
very direct reply my mentor just carries
on his business and I was observing I
was paying attention I was asking myself
question why does Allen do it this way
why does he do marketing that's way I
was taking notes I was reflecting I was
thinking that's what makes me different
so my mentor opened the door for me and
they both did but I was the one that
walks through it I was the one that took
what they taught me and implement it and
created this success created Dan Locke
today very much i molded myself i
structure this person that's in front of
now I've got a really special bonus clip
from Dan on how to aim big that I think
you're gonna enjoy but before that it's
time for the three-point landing
questions time to move from just
watching another video to actually
taking action in your life or your
business and if you're feeling bold
leave your answers in the comments below
here we go question number one who is a
mentor that you would like to learn from
number two how can you invest in that
relationship and number three how can
you learn by just observing what they're
doing
I saw this book Monday on eBay
I was just browsing around to look at
some stuff and I saw the title
captivated me it's called your first
hundred million mmm
fun what kind of book is this like
that's a pretty bossy title as a
copywriter right that's a good title
right I click on it and I saw that the
price was $400 us for a book I thought
to myself who in the right mind would
spend 40 bucks on weight I click on the
link and he has the first chapter in the
listing I read I read through the first
chapter before you know it I was the
idiot that bought the book I spent 400
bucks I bought the book
yeah I read through the whole book they
had such a big impact on me mm-hmm I
guess at the time I was already looking
for the second mentor because I was
already experienced success and Alan
wasn't well and I was looking for
something more and when I saw Dan penny
I can't pick damn right I saw big Dan
it's like this is the guy I wanna learn
from mm-hmm I called the castle just
straight up I just called a castle how
did you get the number it's all need a
book yeah right
now of course when I first called called
Castle you got the gatekeeper but I went
through a lot of like different things
and I went to the castle seminar and
that's how and their time big Dan wasn't
as popular as today it was I remember
when I went to the castle is like four
or five guys I was one of them he did it
once a year I think in the time he was
maybe in semi-retirement with Hyneman
and that's again he's been my mentor now
for more than 10 years
keep in mind I was at a time before the
20 point be 25-ish 26 something like
that then what's making good money
wasn't give me a half a million whenever
a year half nine year how a million
years something like that and I would
call
Victor and said tell me you know hey man
you know I'm pretty good point someone
years old making half a million but I
was Mia put any guys right right you
feel pretty good about yourself right
point someone years I'm pretty smart
right and especially after listening to
his voice and make some changes so I
call him a talk so hey you know so so he
asked me how are you doing oh man you
know do the stuff and all do
stuff right so how much money you're
making now you know half half a million
bucks pretty good silence so he said so
what about you're half a millionaire
yeah yeah yeah that's him that always
doesn't matter what I do every time I
talk to him it's nothing yeah whatever
you I I'm doing whatever compared what
he's done is nothing he always gives you
context to the bigger game they go good
hi this is Dan Locke if you're a fan of
Evans work if you want to know exactly
how the model my success I want to
invite you to join me for a special
online training all you have to do is
click on a link below you can join me
for absolutely no charge so click a link
below and I will see you in class
if you want more Dane Locke check out
the top ten rules video I made on him
the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
it is a habit so it is staying poor it's
also not an act it's nothing just
happens to you it is a habit